- [Voiceover] This circle
represents one whole.
This circle right here
If we know that, we can
answer what fraction
of the circle is shaded in blue below?
So down here.
What fraction is in blue?
Let's start back up here with the whole.
This whole is divided into one, two, three
equal size pieces, so
it's divided into thirds,
three equal size pieces.
And each of those pieces,
each of those pie pieces,
is 1/3, is one of the thirds.
So knowing that, let's go
down here to these ones
and lets see how many of these 1/3 pieces.
Here's 1/3, another 1/3,
another 1/3 shaded in blue,
another one and another one.
So we have one, two,
three, four, five thirds.
We have 5/3 shaded in blue below.